let me ask you this weird question about
the fields medal which is the
nobel prize in mathematics do you think
since we're talking about computers
there will one day
come a time when uh a computer an ai
system will win a fields medal
no of course that's what a human would
say
why not it's is that like that's like my
captcha that's like the proof that i'm a
human
yeah what does how does he want me to
answer
is there something interesting to be
said about that
yeah i mean i am tremendously interested
in
what ai can do in pure mathematics i
mean it's of course
it's a parochial interest right you're
like why am i interested in like how it
can like help feed the world or help
solve like there's such problems i'm
like can i do
more math like what can i do we all have
our interests right um
but i think it is a really interesting
conceptual
question and here too i think
um it's important to be kind of
historical because it's certainly true
that there's lots of things that we used
to call research in mathematics
that we would now call computation yeah
tasks that we've now
offloaded to machines like you know in
1890 somebody could be like here's my
phd thesis i
computed all the invariants of this
polynomial ring under the action of some
finite group doesn't matter what
those words mean just it's like
something that in 1890
would take a person a year to do and
would be a valuable thing that you might
want to know and it's still a valuable
thing that you might want to know but
now you
type a few lines of code in macaulay or
sage
or magma and you just have it so we
don't think of that as
math anymore even though it's the same
thing what's macaulay sage and manga oh
those are computer algebra programs so
those are like sort of bespoke systems
that lots of mathematicians use that's
similar to maple
and yeah oh yeah so similar to maple and
mathematica yeah okay but
a little more specialized but yeah it's
programs that work with symbols
and allow you to do can you do proofs
can you do kind of little
little leaps and proofs they're not
really built for that and that's a whole
other
story but these tools are part of the
process of mathematics now
right they are now for most
mathematicians i would say part of the
process of mathematics and so
um you know there's a story i tell in
the book which i'm fascinated by which
is
you know so far attempts
to get ais to prove interesting theorems
have not
done so well doesn't mean they can it's
actually a paper i just saw which
has a very nice use of a neuron that
defined counter examples to conjecture
somebody said like well maybe this is
always that yeah and you can be like
well let me sort of train an ai to sort
of try to find
things where that's not true and it
actually succeeded now in this case if
you look at the things that it found
you say like okay i mean
these are not famous conjectures yes
okay so like somebody wrote this down
maybe this is so
um looking at what the ai came up with
you're like
you know i bet if like five grad
students had thought about that problem
they wouldn't know
that i mean when you see it you're like
okay that is one of the things you might
try if you sort of like
put some work into it still it's pretty
awesome right but
the story i tell in the book which i'm
fascinated by is
um there is there's
okay we're gonna go back to knots it's
cool there's a knot called the conway
knot
after john conway who maybe we'll talk
about a very interesting character also
yes there's a small tangent
somebody i was supposed to talk to and
unfortunately he passed away and
he's he's somebody i find is an
incredible mathematician incredible
human being
oh and i am sorry that you didn't get a
chance because having had the chance to
talk to him a lot when i was you know
when i was a postdoc
um yeah you missed out there's no way to
sugarcoat it i'm sorry that you didn't
get that chance
yeah it is what it is so knots
yeah so there was a question and again
it doesn't matter the technicalities of
the question but it's a question of
whether the knot is sliced it has to do
with um
something about what kinds of
three-dimensional surfaces in four
dimensions can be bounded by this knob
but never mind what it means it's some
question
and it's actually very hard to compute
whether or not is slice
or not and in particular
the question of the conway knot whether
it was slice or not
was particularly vexed um
until it was solved just a few years ago
by lisa picarillo who actually now that
i think of it was here in austin i
believe she was a grad student at ut
austin at the time i didn't even realize
there was an austin connection to this
story until i started
telling it she is in fact i think she's
now at mit so she's basically following
you around
if i remember correctly the reverse
there's a lot of really interesting
richness to this
story one thing about it is her paper
was rather
was very short it was very short and
simple nine pages of which two were
pictures
uh very short for like a paper solving a
major conjecture
and it really makes you think about what
we mean by difficulty in mathematics
like do you say oh actually the problem
wasn't difficult because you could solve
it so simply or do you say like well no
evidently it was difficult because like
the world's top topologist many you know
worked on it for 20 years and nobody
could solve it so therefore it is
difficult
or is it that we need sort of some new
category of things that
about which it's difficult to figure out
that they're not difficult
i mean this is the computer science
formulation
but the sort of the the journey to
arrive
at the simple answer may be difficult
but once you have the answer
it will then appear simple and i mean
there might be a large category i hope
there's a large
uh set of such
solutions because um
you know once we stand at the end of the
scientific process that we're at the
very beginning
of or at least it feels like i hope
there's just simple answers to
everything
that will look and it'll be simple laws
that govern the universe
simple an explanation of what is
consciousness of what is
love is mortality fundamental to life
what's the meaning of life
uh are are humans special or we're just
another sort of reflection of
uh and all that is beautiful uh
in the universe in terms of like life
forms all of it is life and just
has different when taken from a
different perspective is
all life can seem more valuable or not
but really it's all part of the same
thing
all those will have a nice like two
equations maybe one equation
why do you think you want those
questions to have simple answers
i think just like symmetry in the
breaking of symmetry is beautiful
somehow there's something beautiful
about simplicity
i think it so it's aesthetic it's
aesthetic yeah i
or but it's aesthetic in the way that uh
happiness is an aesthetic
like uh why is that so joyful that a
simple explanation
that governs a large number of cases is
really appealing
even when it's not like obviously we
get a huge amount of trouble with that
because oftentimes
it doesn't have to be connected with
reality or even that explanation could
be exceptionally harmful
most of like the world's history that
has
that was governed by hate and violence
had a very simple explanation at the
court
that was used to cause the violence and
the hatred so like we get into trouble
with that
but why is that so appealing and in this
nice forms
in mathematics like you look at the
einstein papers
why are those so beautiful and why is
the andrew wiles proof of the farm
ozlast theorem
not quite so beautiful like what's
beautiful about that story
is the human struggle of like the human
story of perseverance
of the drama of not knowing if the proof
is correct and ups and downs and all
those kinds of things that's the
interesting part
but the fact that the proof is huge and
nobody understands well from my
outsider's perspective nobody
understands what the heck it is
uh is is not as beautiful as it could
have been
i wish it was what vermont originally
said which is
you know it's it's not
it's not small enough to fit in the
margins of this page
but maybe if he had like a full page or
maybe a couple post-it notes he would
have enough to do the proof
you